hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be reaction video all about
Constantine coming on arrow flash of two
worlds the first image of Jay Garrick
all kinds of awesome stuff from the DC
TV universe this week the biggest news
in my mind is actually Constantine
coming on arrow they had previously not
announced that Stephen Amell ran this
big Twitter campaign early in the year
when they announced the Constantine was
officially cancelled just try and drum
up some interest from the network now he
doesn't have a producer credit on arrow
but he's the lead star so his opinion
does hold weight with the producers and
they're all really huge fans of the
Constantine people so they were happy to
try and use the character but the wrench
in the plan is that NBC and the CW have
to come to an agreement to share the
character because technically NBC still
owns the property it looks like whatever
they did behind the scenes it all worked
out because now Constantine once he
comes on the show he'll be cannon to
arrow in the flash that whole universe
meaning he can keep coming back and
that's really the important thing in my
mind the fact that they can use that
character in the future if they want
they've already talked about how arrow
is getting heavily into mysticism this
year Constantine is just full blown
magic they did explain what his arc is
going to be so what's gonna happen is is
he'll have a one-off appearance he's
going to help them resurrect a character
that they could not normally resurrect
with the Lazarus Pit the way Marc
Guggenheim explained it is is they're
going to use him to resurrect Sarah
Lance because she's been dead for more
than a year in the Lazarus Pit really
only works on people that have been dead
for less than that
Thea is a really good example like if
you if you're a freshly dead person
within a couple days you're totally good
the hottub lazarus pit will make you all
better
but by the time they do the episode
Sarah Lance will have been dead for
about a year so that's like it's a long
time she's been decomposing this whole
time presumably picture like one of the
walkers from Walking Dead getting dumped
in the Lazarus Pit I have no I have no
idea what they're gonna make her look
like on the show I will be a little
upset if they make her look just as
pretty as she was when she died because
their suspension of disbelief and
there's just ridiculousness if she's
been in the ground for a year she's
gonna look a little gross
they didn't say which episode that's
going to be my guess is that it's going
to be like in the the latter half of the
first part of the season meaning it'll
be closer to episode 7 8 9 we do know
that the big like flash versus arrow
crossover this year is going to
the Vandal Savage episode the episode
that brings him into the universe the
first time we see him
that's Episode a des Beaux shows so the
Constantine episode could either come
like right before that or it could come
right after I know a lot of you are
confused about the teaser that they
released because there is like a trailer
they released a bunch of footage but
really that was a promo intended to sell
the show to networks like they wanted to
sell advertisers they buy space and they
can make money on the show don't be
surprised if all that footage gets
reshot or recut for the actual episodes
Hawkgirl is a really good example like
they had a limited amount of time to do
her so like whenever she's in that
teaser trailer she's really blurry
really dark and really far in the
background you you can't really make her
out but when she comes on the flash and
arrow we'll probably get to see her
full-on CG with the wings and the helmet
everything in Hawkman too for that
matter but they haven't really explained
the Hawkgirl Hawkman dynamic yet
speaking of which next big thing onto
the flash they only really teased the
first look at Jay Garrick and it's
really like a small teaser but this is
what his costume is gonna look like they
mocked up this comic book cover just in
honor of the first time the Barry Allen
met Jay Garrick in flash of two worlds I
think I already talked about that when I
did my multiverse video so I had a link
in the description I just explained the
story behind the flash of two worlds how
Barry meets Jay Garrick for the first
time made no mistake though they are
doing the multiverse on the flash I mean
they're just kind of dipping their toe
in the water if you've been reading the
comics it's not going to be like
full-blown convergence type stuff it's
not going to get that crazy but my
initial reaction is is that it looks
great
it actually looks closer to this version
of Jay Garrick he's had a couple
modifications to his costume throughout
the comics not as many as the flash
proper like for all the different
characters to wear the mantle but still
it is a little more contemporary it's
more like a jacket that he wears with a
pair of pants as opposed to the old
school t-shirt look and because he's
going to be a contemporary of Barry
Allen just from earth-2 I'm expecting it
to be made of tech fabric just like
Barry's is made of tech fabric to the
way that costumes are made in the comics
is a little bit different from the TV
show it's a little more practical the
way the TV show explains it
Barry's costume is made from like a
super advanced firefighter costume that
they weren't using so I'm assuming that
Jay Garrick's is going to be something
close to that too but I'm really hoping
for is that he get
the white emblem like the new costume
after he meets Jay Garrick like as a
result of visiting earth too he has to
make a new costume and they just they
magic up the white logo in for those
wondering this girl down here this is
patty spivot it's kind of hard to tell
but she's wearing a police uniform top
and pants I know a lot of people thought
that it might be felicity because she
wears like those power suits but if you
look at this picture of the actress
Chantal Van Santen behind the scenes
she's already wearing the plainclothes
outfit so that's the outfit she's
wearing in this flash edit don't think
that just because she's fallen in there
helping her that she's going to be a
damsel in distress this was only done
this way so that it would fit within the
context of the cover art from the
classic flash of two worlds comic I just
I saw a lot of people complaining
they're like aw is she gonna be another
damsel in distress no this is just gonna
be for fun she's going to be a badass
police officer in the context of the
series so so don't worry about that
this is actually a full res picture of
the season 2 costume but the way the
light plays on it it doesn't look
exactly like it's going to look on the
TV show really those are the big two
announcements vixen is coming in two
weeks but they didn't spend a whole lot
of time promoting that the CW seed
service it's like their version of HBO
now that's where those episodes are
going to drop I'll be doing weekly
videos for it so just keep your eyes
peeled for that I'll do videos just like
I do for the flash and arrow so I'll try
to make sure that everybody understands
vixen when we start out just because
she's not as big a comic book character
is the flash or a green arrow let me
know that what do you think about
Constantine coming on arrow and what do
you think about jay garrick's suit just
to clarify a lot of people were
wondering if Constantine had been
cancelled I guess maybe you know maybe
they didn't hear me talking about it
earlier this year yes it was flat out
cancelled it hasn't gone to another
network so the show is dead but the
character now will be part of arrow in
the flash and just because he's coming
on arrow he's only coming on arrow that
doesn't mean he will not also go on
flash at some point it's just that the
flash is more of a science-based show so
the more like the science-based
characters go to the flash and arrow is
going into mysticism so more the magic
based characters will be going to arrow
so congratulations to Matt Ryan Stephen
Amell has you now what about trailers
though I know a lot of you are asking
about official flash and arrow trailers
for the next season what I'm thinking is
is that they might use those to promote
the
and premiere so because they didn't drop
him this week they might end up dropping
him in a couple weeks whenever vixen
premieres and that'll be in two weeks on
Tuesday so it's August 25th but remember
it's digital it's not on TV
it's CWC calm you might have to use like
a VPN workaround if you're in another
country I don't know if it's accessible
outside of the u.s. everybody get hyped
though vixen will run for six weeks and
at the end of that arrow in the flash
will premiere like that that's kind of
how its intended to go it'll be like six
weeks and then BAM premiere so just
giant high fives to everyone all around
this is really like the best possible
outcome the arrow and flash are just
totally nailing it so far just in the
stuff that I've been seeing so far so
just in case you haven't seen it you can
click here for my flash multiverse video
that'll kind of can explain how the
multiverse work for DC Comics and Jay
Garrick's origins story
and you can click here to watch the
Vixen trailer and learn all about her
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow